chaque année la grande distribution
jette un million trois cent
quatre-vingt-dix mille tonnes d'aliments
et des fruits qu'on peut plus maintenir
au rio parce qu'ils sont défraîchis
gaspillage fait dans l'indifférence
générale
pendant des décennies des aliments
encore consommables mais dont la date de
péremption approche des légumes ou des
fruits un peu flétrie tout y passe et
les poubelles débordent
mais avec la crise de 2008 par nécessité
ou bien par conscience citoyenne
certains s'indignent de toutes ces
denrées comestibles jetez moi le
gaspillage ça me scandalise pour ça
regardez ça enfin des fruits qui sont
parfaits mais magnifique
ils n'ont pas le moindre défaut c'est
pas du bouton du tout ça c'est
parfaitement remplir c'est à peine s'il
ya besoin de laver alors pour redorer le
blason de leur enseigne ou par charité
parfois certaines grandes surfaces
prennent l'initiative de donner à des
associations plutôt que de jeter exemple
dès 2010 il y a trois mois tous ses
invendus finissez à la poubelle j'étais
horrifiée toute la nourriture qu'on
jetait alors que des gens meurent de
faim c'est vrai que c'est servir en face
à ce gaspillage le magasin a mis en
place un partenariat avec les restos du
coeur des initiatives trop rares alors
en 2016
une loi est votée les distributeurs
n'auront plus le droit de jeter
ils devront faire don de leurs surplus
mais malgré cette loi contraignante le
gaspillage perdure et ça avant même que
les produits n'arrivent dans les rayons
en cause les calibrages imposé par la
grande distribution producteurs mille
tonnes produites chaque année
mais dont 30% ne finiront pas sur les
étals des magasins celle qu'ils sont pas
commercialisable donc ce sont les
petites tout ça les petites pommes
ce sont les pommes qui ont des défauts
voilà un défaut un exemple type coincé
uniquement une friction d'une branche
la grande distribution n'est pas le seul
coupable dans le grand gâchis
alimentaire
loin de là d'après le rapport garraud
elle ne pèse que pour 13,6 pour cent du
problème global loin derrière les foyers
qui représentent eux 40% du gaspillage
alimentaire en moyenne un français jette
chaque année entre 20 et 30 kg de
nourriture
[Musique]